i hesitate
to take anecdotal evidence
as like final scientific conclusions but
it does seem
i've eaten quite a bit of belcampo me
for example and it's just my body seems
to respond
like is less bothered by it meaning like
uh
less inflamed i just feel better because
i mostly eat a meat diet
and it does seem to be a little bit of a
difference what kind of meat i eat
where it comes from i don't know if
that's
my own psychology also i mean there is
an aspect to like
when you know that the meat came from a
good place and all the ways we've
we've defined good you feel better about
it
and that has an effect like decreased
stress so i'm a huge believer in that
like
outside of just nutrition how you feel
about the whole experience is a huge
impact but
it does feel like the meat itself is
actually just leading to less
inflammation for me or like less
like the blow blowed bloated feeling and
all those negative effects that could
come with me
versus like certain other ground beef
that i eat like store bought
chicken breast or steak all those kinds
of things
my my body's a little bit more uh works
a little bit harder to process that food
it feels like
i don't know if there's science to that
but sort of anecdotally that seems to be
the case
omega-6s are a big part of that for in
the case of the you eat a lot of beef
yes you love beef yeah and so
in a conventional beef product it's a 1
to 30 ratio
of omega-3s to sixes and it can
sometimes 1 to 20 1 to 30 but that's the
wrong direction
in our beef it's you know as low as one
to one
right so that and the omega-6s are
what's part of inflammation
right now you know they the magic in
animals is that they're incredibly
efficient processors right
and in the same way that you know the
the
the body can protect uh us from you know
can
process and take out tons of things that
are toxic out of the environment i mean
animals bodies can do that too
so the beauty of meat is that it can be
pretty clean you know things like
roundup and stuff don't end up in the
meat when we have antibiotics
in our meat we're not worried about
getting like tetracycline from the
chicken breast
what we're worried about is the workers
getting tetracycline the chicken growing
faster than it should the meat being
chewier and not as
high quality so they but the actual
antibiotics don't the animal's
great at filtering that right they get
that out so you have to
think about meat not as like
contamination of like oh there's going
to be some of that garbage they used
in the farming in my meat um but it's
the more subtle things it's the fat
ratio it's the protein density
and there's also uh just i think
in my experience um there's just more
complex flavor
and things that taste more complex this
is you know science backs this up
they fill you up faster so if you're
looking to limit
you know to to eat for fullness and but
not eat
as many calories more complex foods are
the way to do that
and that hit you know you hit your
satiety he'll help you hit that society
so things like i mean all the key um you
know amino acids that help you feel full
mostly from meat right um so those are
that's part of it like it but all meats
have those
then there's other kind of
micronutrients and things around that
complex flavor that help you feel full
faster
you